Speaker 1: The reaction from Republicans to
Joe Biden's first speech before a joint session
of Congress was pathetic, childish and ignorant,
which are three adjectives that they often
I could be describing.
Almost anything the Republican Party has done
over the last few years as pathetic, childish
and ignorant.
And it would be accurate.
Republican Senator Tim Scott gave the formal
rebuttal and we'll get to a couple of clips
of that.
But Fox News gave the informal rebuttal, as
I'm calling it, and we're going to look at
clips of that as well.
Immediately after the speech, in an interview
with Fox's Sean Hannity.
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy again
brought up that Joe Biden wants to control
how much red meat each American eats.
This was never believable from the start.
It's now been totally debunked.
And a different Fox News program actually
apologized for falsely reporting that Joe
Biden wanted to control meat eating.
McCarthy doesn't care.
He repeats it again.
He just
Speaker 3: continues.
He wants control of your life.
He's going to control how much meat you can
eat.
Can you imagine that?
Speaker 1: And then here is a FOX News host,
Sean Hannity, complaining about how Joe Biden
walked.
He didn't like the the gates that's guilty
of Joe Biden walking into the speech.
Speaker 3: You watch I call it the Biden shuffle
psycho.
You know, the little baby steps that he takes
as he walks and the little elbows.
Looks like it's an effort.
It doesn't seem to be a vitality in in in
how he approaches this
Speaker 1: very substantive, as you can tell.
And by the way, it's weird to complain about
how Joe Biden walks when Donald Trump had
to be helped down the ramp at West Point by
a military general.
But what do I know?
It seems that people in glass, in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones.
But apparently Sean Hannity having nothing
left but that to do.
Senator Ted Cruz, who, again, you know, earlier
we saw dozing off during Joe Biden's speech,
he summed the speech up this way.
Speaker 3: Well, look, I think the speech
tonight, you could sum up in three words,
boring but radical.
Speaker 1: And then much of the reaction was
not about the proposals, but about masks and
distancing.
Check this out,
Speaker 3: by the way.
This needs to be said.
You know, all of the people in that room,
they've been fully vaccinated.
Congress, they were first in line back in
December.
Do we not have an explanation?
Why can't that room be full?
Why is everyone still wearing masks now?
Speaker 1: Of course, we know the answers
to these questions.
They always they they love, you know, when
when your audience is uninformed and doesn't
know any better, you can ask questions and
pretend we don't have answers and get them
on board by saying, yeah, that why don't we
have the answer to that?
But we have the answers.
The CDC guidelines are vaccinated.
People do not have to wear masks in small
indoor gatherings.
There is still enough of an unvaccinated population
and 50000 cases a day spreading that at a
large event.
People should wear masks regardless of vaccination
status, in part because you don't know everybody's
vaccination status.
The House chamber with 200 people in it, even
if it's not the full five hundred and thirty
five members of Congress plus staff that would
normally be there.
It's not a small group.
Vaccination was not mandatory.
Rand Paul, I think, didn't get his I don't
remember now, but I think, you know, you do
not know the vaccination status of everyone
in the room.
It's not a small group.
That's why it's not super complicated.
That's why they're wearing masks.
Plus, so many of Hannity's followers are so
dumb that if they saw a room full of five
hundred and thirty five people without masks,
they would think it's OK for them and their
unvaccinated friends to start doing whatever
the hell they want.
So the answer is actually quite simple as
to why this is the way it was done.
The defenders of.
Donald Trump also are suddenly very concerned
about the nuances of CDC guidelines.
Here is another from Fox News.
They were never concerned about Trump's rallies
or anything.
Listen to the concern now.
Speaker 4: Well, first, I want to talk about
what I what I'm seeing.
And I thought you mentioned these people who
are all vaccinated being and or social distancing
with their masks on.
That's against CDC guidance.
And it's not just that that's theater.
It actually shows that the United States is
at a weak point when the Congress can't show
up in full to show that the United States
is standing strong after coming out of a pandemic
that was caused by China.
I mean, if you give a joint address to a Congress
that is not even half full, doesn't really
even count as a joint address to Congress,
I mean, I think that's really a question.
The other thing that I
Speaker 1: yes, we look weak because there
weren't more people at Joe Biden's speech.
Give me a break, guys.
Here's one more about this.
Basically, the only thing that Fox News had
to talk about was masking and distancing.
Speaker 4: I think it's worth noting at the
top just the feel of this room and the fact
that he talked a lot in the beginning about
covid, about pulling through covid and getting
through this era that really marked so much
of his candidacy.
And yet you have this new CDC guidance that
came out just this week, which said, and I'll
read it to you, fully vaccinated people can
visit other fully vaccinated people indoors
without wearing masks or social distancing.
So you just have to ask yourself if this is
setting an example, looking forward for the
country of what everyone can expect the country
to be like in this period where people now
have very open availability to vaccines.
Speaker 1: Really asking the tough questions.
In his formal response to Joe Biden, Republican
Senator Tim Scott referred to what he says
was the most inclusive economy of his lifetime
under Donald Trump before covid.
Speaker 5: Thanks to our bipartisan work last
year, job openings are rebounding.
So why do we feel so divided?
Anxious, a nation with so much cause for hope
should not feel so.
Have you let a president who promised to bring
us together should not be pushing agendas
that tear us apart, the American family deserves
better and we know better.
Looks like just before covid, we have the
most inclusive economy in my lifetime.
Speaker 1: You know, I really don't recall
that magical period of bipartisanship and
unity under Trump that Tim Scott is referring
to.
Trump, in fact, statistically has been the
most divisive president in the modern polling
era.
But he wants us to believe it was ginger snaps
and candy waterfalls and rainbows and all
of that stuff.
And overall, I mean, Tim Scott's response
was just very weak.
It felt like it had no testicular fortitude
behind it.
Here's one more clip.
Speaker 5: Our public schools should have
reopened months ago.
Other countries did, private and religious
schools did.
Science has shown for months that schools
are safe, but too often powerful, grown up
set science aside.
And kids like me.
Were left behind,
Speaker 1: of course, more and more schools
are open and things are opening, and it's
like this is your criticism, much of it doesn't
even have to do with Joe Biden.
A lot of these school decisions are state
decisions, individual school decisions.
I know school principals.
I know people on boards of education.
And it's not Joe Biden that's deciding anyway.
So a completely vapid, flaccid, substance
free reaction to Joe Biden's speech, both
in terms of the official response by Republican
Senator Tim Scott and by Fox News.
And the fact that they have nothing substantive
once again, is a sign that Joe Biden is, generally
speaking, on the right track because the critiques
aren't substantive, because Joe Biden is proposing
things that are widely speaking popular.
Necessary and well received by the American
people.
Let me know what you thought of the speech.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.